we um we're at 12 19. let's see if we
can get to 1 300 today
let's see if we can get to 1300 today uh
now
i normally have a notebook at hand but
we're just gonna do it live here
we'll do it live we'll do it live
do it live i can i'll write it and we'll
do it live
all right let's go let's get this show
on the road guys
let's get this show on the road
okay so we're playing at 1200 all right
we'll play the sicilian we
we have and we'll play the accelerated
dragon let's see if he does the open
sitzillion
maybe he goes bishop's okay he does do
the open sicilian and
uh we played this once before the
accelerated dragon
where you get your bishop out very very
quickly now he's gone c3
sort of xqc style and that's not a great
move because it takes away the natural
developing square
from his knight so now after knight f6
we attacked his pawn and he's got to
make this very awkward ooh
okay so he's already pushing a bunch of
pawns and weakening his position
that's a that's a clue that we need to
open up the center asap
so in what way are we going to open the
center up
and and first we're going to castle and
we're going to open it up after we
castle so the move is going to be d5 but
let's not rush with that move
let's castle first he's probably going
to develop his bishop
my guess is perhaps the c4 and that's
actually just going to add more fuel to
the fire because d5 is going to come
with tempo
this move is so strong that he's
disconnected okay bishop b2
and now we go d5 now we don't need to
actually
prevent him from castling that's not
necessarily the entire
point we're just trying to expose the
weaknesses in his position and even if
he castles
uh he doesn't necessarily well whoa
bobby boucher with ten tempted thank you
and a great game
uh amazing stuff the party continues
thank you bobby for the 10 gifted to the
community
that is an adoption of subs indeed okay
so what do we do in this position how do
we continue
accumulating the pressure perhaps you
know just
generally applying more pressure on his
position there's a great square for this
knight and that is the f4 square
yes knight f4 is very typical um
awesome well welcome okay so this
at this level already this is where
tactics come into play right this is
when you need when you need to start
looking at tactics when i look at this
position what do i see
i see the fact that knight takes e2 uh
just sort of exists
so there is a tactic at the end of which
you play knight takes e2 and knight
takes e2 is actually a fork
can anybody find this tactic in its
entirety
can anybody find this tactic in its
entirety and it's and it's a pretty
difficult tactic
so you just take everything on g4 and
there's any touchscreen on g4
there's an etyptian on d4 and actually
we take on deport with the queen
which is actually a very typical type of
tactic i don't even know what to call it
i guess it's removing the defender
but we basically force white's queen
onto a forkable square
then we take the bishop and then we
recapture the queen and weapon piece
so how you see this well that's why we
put knights on acts of squares when you
have a knight like that on f4 okay he's
gone king h1
so he's chosen simply not to recapture
the piece we're just going to move the
bishop back
and we're going to be up a full bishop
with this knight
also making call okay so he's gone into
the end game but this is completely lost
so it's it seems complex but the reality
is if you understand the underlying idea
uh which is the fact that his position
is already almost crumbling then you
should already be looking for tactics to
start
okay and and if you solve this is where
just like solving tactics helps
because if you just solve a lot of
tactics and here we're just going to
infiltrate to the
to the second rank and we're going to
start
the process of completing this game
but uh this is not terribly difficult to
sense this
i i don't want to make it seem like this
is some sort of black magic
the fact is that the knight is on f4 the
bishop money 2 is poorly defended
and so all of these factors put together
are responsible for there being a tactic
i'll i'll fully explain this uh after
the game
okay so he's gone g3 and the knee-jerk
reaction for most people would be to
move this knight right he's attacking
this knight we have to move it
uh but but the reality is we do not have
to move the sign how do i know that well
look take a look at black white's king
for a second
does the king have any squares nope g1
is covered
by our bishop g2 is covered by a rook
so we should already be looking for
mating patterns uh regardless of the
fact that the knight is hanging and we
find one in the form of bishop h3
aiming for the g2 square which is going
to be checkmate
and the game is over so the sicilian is
a great weapon at this level if you know
how to play it
because people are kind of aimlessly
floundering around
and you can see how potent it is once we
open up the center we get the knight to
f4 and we win the game
very very quickly now before we start
the next game i'm just going to explain
what was the point if white captures on
d4
we play queen takes d4 and
this is a very nice move we sacked the
queen temporarily but now the knight
recaptures the bishop and it's a fork
if the king moves away which he should
have done then we actually also take on
b2 and it's another fork
and we see this chain reaction often
like when the position opens up like
this
everything starts collapsing so
i highly highly recommend the
accelerated dragon as a
gateway into the situ if you want to
learn the sicilian but you're
worried about tons of theory and getting
checkmated
the accelerated dragon is very
approachable there isn't
a forbidding amount of theory and the
ideas are relatively easy to understand
and there's a lot of traps
so it's got it all and it's actually not
an objectively bad opening right it's
it's
magnus plays it and it's it's quite
difficult for white to prove an
advantage
even at a grand master level so well
when did i decide to open up the center
well when he played f3
because the moment he played f3 is the
moment that he weakened his bishop it's
the moment he weakened his king side
and when that kind of move is played it
alerts in me the desire to open up the
center
which i could have done immediately but
i decided first to castle just to be a
little bit on the safe side it's not
like he's gonna stop me from playing d5
um how did this escalate well because
he's just not developing
he's just weakening his position okay so
as i said guys i play three
three games at a time and after those
games are concluded i
go through each one in in greater detail
so
let's play the next two games and then i
will answer everybody's questions i
promise
all right let's go e4 and um
okay so he's playing the modern the
modern is uh
an opening where black immediately clean
keto is a suspicion this is an opening
that you might see me playing in blitz
i don't recommend it to beginners
because it requires a very
deep understanding of well how to play
against the center and you basically
yield
control over the center now
how should we play here if we are white
what do we do here
and there's a very brute force approach
which i would recommend
which really tests uh your opponent's
understanding
black is just pushing out a lot of his
pawns he's creating a lot of targets
and we can actually just start attacking
one of these targets well we don't want
to play f4
uh but that's the right idea right we
want to push up onto the h file
we're actually going to play h4 uh you
guys i'm sure have well and he
immediately responds with h5
but what square does h5 actually weaken
where can we actually put one of our
pieces now
and this creates a thread and it
essentially causes a chain reaction i
mean h5 is already a mistake right so we
can bring our bishop to g5
uh he goes bishop f6 uh and
at this point i've already talked about
positional concepts quite a bit and here
i'll reinforce them
by playing bishop f6 he's offering us a
bishop trade which i will accept
and by offering us a bishop trade look
at his dark squares
they have been tremendously weakened by
this move g6 and e6
how do we cement our control over those
dark squares
yes beware is correct we go e5 and now
the f6 square is firmly under our
control
but let's not forget that we also need
to develop our pieces uh we need to
combine
control over the dark squares with piece
development so so let's first
take a moment to complete our
development okay let's first complete
our development and i always
remind people of how important that is
now
we're just going to go to nf3 and later
we're going to try to get this knight
over f6
before we do that we can actually make
another development move here
uh with tempo and it's a great move it
prepares castles long
now and it attacks one of our opponent's
pieces and that is the move queen to d2
and later on you can imagine that the
queen
can perhaps maneuver to g5 and uh start
attacking perhaps it's the knight ants
ends up on f6 and now we just uh
maneuver the knight over to this
beautiful fortress on f6 where it's
protected
sorry outpost on f6 where it's protected
by the pawn on e5
pawn on e5 is protected by the pawn on
d4 and that is the power of a pawn chain
right it's very hard to break that up
now how are we going to actually
continue well knight d7 that's a very
very good move for our opponents
uh which i will be honest with you guys
i i underestimated this move
uh but but part of chess mastery is the
ability to react
to unforeseen developments right i
didn't entirely appreciate this move
myself
and one of the things that players
really really struggles uh
really really struggle with is the
ability to admit
their mistakes the ability to just say
you know what i
you know i played this move and uh the
move wasn't great so
guess what i'm just gonna bring bring
the knight back to e4
okay time to retreat uh and and uh my
long time coach for many years gregory
kaidanov
he called this saying sorry right
sometimes you just have to say sorry
that's a lot better than stubbornly
continuing with your plan so now we're
going to castle
and this queen from d2 needs to be
brought to a more active square in order
to act as the glue
that'll keep the e5 bond better defended
now we're just starting to accumulate
pieces on the king side in preparation
for an attack our opponent
is trading bishops fine i don't care
let's trade
and how are we going to go about
continuing the attack
in order to continue the attack we need
more pieces we have a very typical
attacking mechanism that can be used to
bring another piece into the attack
what am i talking about it's the rl
those are the initials of the
strategy that we can put on the board
right now we can double
we can also rook lift uh both
options involve our rooks i really
actually like the double idea of
doubling rooks on the d file
why are we doubling rooks on the default
well we're doubling rooks in order to
attack the knight
why are we trying to attack the knight
because we want to get our knight to f6
just because we retreated that knight
from f6 earlier
doesn't mean that that's not a good idea
in the long term
uh we want to put that knight on f6
that's going to be huge for our attack
and in order to do that we'll have to
get that knight out of d7
uh we could have sacked on d7 but i
didn't see a need to do that i think
that would have been a little bit too
drastic
and now he's got to move his knight i
don't see a way for him to defend it
if he goes rick d8 we're going to have
insurmountable pressure on the d file
we're going to be able to explode
so he's gone rook d8 typical mistake
what he doesn't realize is this rook on
d8
is in our cross hairs if his knight
moves from d7 will be able to capture on
d8 so now a very simple tactic wins the
game we go knight f6
if he takes on f6 we don't immediately
grab the rook on d8 what do we do first
if he takes on f6 how do we win the
maximal amount of material
we actually play e takes f6 check
intermediate move intermediate
and that's how you find intermediate
moves right you don't rush into just
assuming that you take the first
material that presents itself
you just take a second and ask yourself
all right wait how can i get the most
out of the position
okay i can take the knight with check
first and then i can take the rock
and okay so now it is time to the victor
belong the spoils
we take on d7 not only have we won a
piece but our rook is now at a prime
attacking
location uh in order to bring the most
benefit out of that location we need to
involve
one more piece into the attack and those
dark squares okay queen before
let's be on alert he's made a tricky
move gotta attend to this
but just because it's the end game
doesn't mean that the attack is
evaporated
what move am i talking about how do we
bring that final piece
into the attack with devastating effect
knight to g5 is correct
we're to take on f7 or take on e6
because the pawn is pinned
and essentially the game is over we are
also a piece
so let's just take all of the pieces
yeah intermezzo is the
sort of italian way to say intermediate
move
uh so here there's many ways to win um
one piece of general advice that i have
to share with
you guys in such endgames is uh the
common phrase
that is used here in endgames in general
which is do not hurry
uh that's sort of a russian kind of
maxim
that's that's told often to beginners
and to kids do not hurry in the end game
and that means several things first of
all there's a tendency to play fast in
the end game and second while there's a
tendency to play fast
on the board right there's a tendency to
just try to rush your ideas but
sometimes you just want to improve your
position and that is the most effective
way
of um you know of of
converting an advantage quite often
let's play the last game and then we
will analyze
okay so we're playing a russian serota
that means orphan orphan nine okay
c5 um c4 okay so he's playing the smith
mora
probably nope he plays queen takes d4
not
a good move why not what do we do
i know knight c6 yeah this is weird
um he's just letting us develop a tempo
and now we develop again and his queen
is going to get in the way
now he's playing sort of the center game
against the sicilian but that's not how
this works
now you guys already know from so many
games that i played
how do we deal with this kind of opening
play
what move do we make and what is the
strategy behind that move
and this is not the only way of playing
we can also fianchetto our bishop that
would be a great idea
but let's open up the center with d5
right
our first impulse in situations when we
are anticipating a big lead in
development
is to open up the center but to do so
strategically right you don't want to
sacrifice like eight pieces to open up
the center you want to do so
in a manner conducive to your further
development
okay he's gone bishop d3 um and
we have several approaches here we can
we can take and take out of his bishop
and that would be fine but uh let's
let's uh control some more of the center
let's go e5 and open up our bishop
and control some more of the center we
want him to be the one to take on d5 why
uh because then we capture back with a
knight and our knight is nicely placed
in the center
okay let's continue our development in a
very
uh non-intrusive way and i've made this
point to you guys before
not every development move has to be
equivalent to finding a
coronavirus vaccine like it's fine to
develop
in a simple straightforward manner and
that is what i'm going to do with the
bishop b7 but isn't the bishop passive
here like why are you not putting it on
before
well because we're just trying to
develop and castle right you don't
always have to look for
the most aggressive square for every one
of your pieces
uh then you're just going to you know
you're going to lose on time on move
five
uh and when when you talk about
development
the role of development is to put your
pieces on decent serviceable squares
not to just like you know
i don't know go crazy and checkmate
every opponent on move five
queen d2 is is a very weird move i
assume that's a mouse slip he blunders a
fork
the knight defends the pawn and so he
loses a piece
and that was the consequences of him
moving his screen around in the opening
okay don't over return that's right
i am not going to flag uh don't worry
i i am a professional
okay um
rumor has it i've played a couple bullet
games in my life
okay so he has to decide which bc gives
up
um he's busted either way and i don't
think he's very happy right now
by the time he's expending here
okay let me let me um change the title
so uh if i were him and i had to
actually
make something out of this okay i would
not do this because now in addition to
giving up a piece
he's up and look at this he's ruining
his pawn structure and so
in terms of we've talked about two
methods of converting
uh material advantages one is to trade
as much as possible the other is
attacking
what does his move tell us about which
of these plants we should choose
do you guys think we should now trade
all the pieces or should we
close the avenue of negotiation between
the queens and start attacking clearly
we should attack right
and this isn't rocket science he's just
weakened his king like this
the way that we would attack is by
playing knight to d4 knight td4
closes the avenue of negotiation between
the queens and
we are actually kind of forking the pawn
on f3 forking a fork
as i like to say and we're attacking the
bishop forcing the bishop back to e2
then we're going to take on h3 and mate
is going to come within three four moves
because his king is wide open okay he's
giving up his queen instead
both has gambit and the game is over
so that was relatively straightforward
that decision logic uh
is i think relatively instructive we
kind of detect the clues in the position
he resigns
and that was very straightforward okay
let's very quickly go through the uh
the three games we played now in this
game
uh there was a question about going e5
and the movie e5
in general i see a lot of players
falling for a temptation like this but
when you look at this move positionally
what is the drawback what is the
drawback of
the move e5
if you look at it from a positional
standpoint the bishop now aims at a wall
i personally and
it's not just a personal thing you've
got to be very careful about the
situation
because i don't know when you're going
to get the spawn out of e5
and it's a pretty big deal when you
block your bishop like this so you
better have a pretty damn good reason
to do that and when there is an
equivalent way of opening the center
to make this kind of positional
concession is a little bit dubious now
it's still not a very bad move because
you could follow up with d5
and essentially later on you can move
that pawn out of e5 to e4
but i would say be very careful about
what i call
static again i'm saying what i call but
i didn't invent any of these terms
um trust educators far greater than me
invented them
but basically the concept of static
weaknesses right weaknesses that cannot
be corrected uh
very easily and might be essentially
permanent
that is what you need to be very careful
about and that involves and includes
things like making a piece very bad by
having it stare at a wall or
weakening a particular square for a long
period of time
those things uh should be done very very
carefully and you should only do them if
you have a very very good reason to do
that
okay the movie e6 would be similarly
dubious because it would weaken
this d6 square and i've shown you guys
an example of
why you want to be very careful in the
sicilian
specifically about combining the moves
g6 and e6 and part of the reason
is that you leave unattended this
complex of dark
squares okay and he can slam that
outpost into d6
right off the bat if you guys want i've
and i've actually showed you guys
uh a couple of illustrative examples of
what happens when a knight lands on d6
like
this it can paralyze black's entire
queen side
uh for the rest of the game i mean it's
particularly if a
pawn were to then advance and support
that knight
so let me actually give you a very
straightforward example of
of such a game from my own career
and i well
there's a couple of there's a couple of
games i could show you a couple of
positive experiences and negative
experiences
but here is a good illustration
so this is one of my this is actually
one of my best games
uh i was in i am when this game was
played i
i was white okay this was after i got my
third gm norm
uh but i was still like and i am and i
was playing a pretty strong gm as you
guys can see thank you peanut butter
jello time
and look what happens i sacrifice a pawn
as usual
um and i managed to get a knight to d6
and this is the sicilian
look at this knight very very carefully
it basically remains there
for most of the game completely
completely paralyzing black's position
and what i'm trying to do here is i'm
accumulating the pressure e5
here comes the pawn that guards the
knight it's chess-based guys
it's not microsoft word it's just
modeled after microsoft and now a very
nice move knight f5
the knight basically leaves d6 but only
to sacrifice itself
what is the idea after g takes f5
what is the idea and it's a very simple
move it's not really a sacrifice because
he can't really take bishop h6 and his
checkmate
because this bishop blocks the f pawn so
he can't set up this link between the
queen and the bishop
uh and so he was forced to go up 88 and
now i simply collect the pawns
but the rest is very simple bishop f6
and i hunted his king down to checkmate
g4 he resigned here because after king
f4
uh it's just checkmate so yeah uh this
was a pretty good game
and you can see that it all started from
me establishing
that knight on d6 the game was very
one-sided he
just didn't manage to do anything
okay so that was a positive experience
but i also had a negative experience of
weakening
that particular square uh and here you
guys go fast or rewind i suppose to
2005.
i am 1800 and i'm playing against this
guy
and guess what i do g6 and e6
boom boom yeah bing bang boom
okay one after the other and he wins a
rook okay
so this game was a cautionary tale to me
about not
playing g6 and e6 together in the
sicilian because it leaves these squares
unattended
i won the game in the end i managed to
swindle him
but well and by the way those of you who
are how did you i have a database of my
games
from you know as early as 2004 onwards
and i just searched it
um i remember roughly speaking the
opening from all of my games
so i can sort of track them down quickly
uh particularly the memorable games
so in any case i won't have i won't show
the entire game i managed to win his
night back
and i made things interesting and then i
want his rook back and
well i um i played a nice game to
swindle him but the fact remains
this was my cautionary tale
during the reset of the
server i will uh i will show some more
of my early games
okay so in any case that's the rationale
behind d5 long story short
and then of course we find this tactic
and the rest is very simple
in this other game the move h4 is what i
want to explain
i want people to understand the logic
behind the move h4 what is the logic
behind this move
um well idle strategist uh chess
base is not a competitor for chess.com
so i'm allowed to use it uh
i wouldn't use leaches for example it's
just
base is not a playing server it's just a
server to analyze
uh although it does have a playing
server as well
uh so this move has two well it has one
main goal and then it has a positive
byproduct
the positive byproduct of this move is
that it controls the g5 square and it
prepares our bishop's development to g5
but let me be very clear as obama would
say a little more before
lumber before uh this doesn't only
protect g5 we also use the pawn as a
battering ram
and we prepared to advance it to h5 why
would we advance the ponce h5 because
now this pawn on g6 is weak
and the pawn from h5 would threaten to
open the h file which could be good for
us
or it can advance all the way to h6 and
now it's literally a bone in black's
throat
the bishop has to go either to f6 and
now the knight can't develop
f6 or it has to go to f8 so
this brings to the table some very
unpleasant consequences
okay that is why i really really like
the move h4
our opponent understandably enough
played h5 but now we get our bishop to
this incredibly
just solid outpost on g5 he tries to
dislodge it
but in doing so he weakens all of these
dark squares
around his king which after completing
our development
we are able to occupy with our pieces
and use as the basis
for future attack this move knight f6
was a mistake uh i missed the move
knight d7 and here we just said all
right
i'm sorry i'm going back let's complete
our development first double the rooks
and only now
on a second attempt we go knight f6 only
when we're ready
to do okay uh we have a great question
from noisy miner what if
black would have played the cunning h6
the idea of h6 is he brings the g5
square under his control
and if we go h5 he goes g5 well when i
look at this pawn on g5
i see a hook i've explained the concept
of a hook before
what can we do with this so how do we
exploit what should white do here
this is a very very typical sequence
right h5 and now the following move
which is what let's rip
open that king side boom
f4 if he takes look at his bishop we
might put a queen on g4 i mean that
entire kingside
is in a world of hurt and so white has
uh tremendous attacking possibilities
here and i'm not claiming that um
that white is uh winning but i i tru i
do
think that this is well i i think this
is um
one second
when do you know when to blow up side
center well we have the center control
we have
more development than our opponent and
so we kind of know that we should
open up the center in any case that was
that game and then the final game was a
very simple one
this move bishop b7 is just what i
wanted to emphasize
a lot of people would want to play the
move d4 but but the move d4 would be
counterproductive
uh and i want to make the point here
that it's not all about
grabbing space in in chess okay
uh because the move d4 it may look
productive but what it actually does is
it closes up the center
it closes up the center and it allows
white to to justify
his you know over zealousness
with his queen because now the queen
comes back to e2 where it's perfectly
safe
and when the center is closed a lead of
development isn't as easily
and strongly felt as it is with the
center open for obvious reasons right
you know it's just that the center is
closed so you start the slow maneuvering
game
okay so i just wanted to make the point
that d4
uh is a move that may look good but in
reality it closes the center and that
favors
uh generally speaking the side that is
lacking in development
any questions
any questions or shall we move on to the
next set of games wow
2500 viewers crazy
question by mariel 100 yes go ahead
how can we assess what please be
specific
i would love to be a high school teacher
yes
history maybe i will be one day
when do you move the rook up and then to
the center i'm not again i it's hard for
me to answer those kinds of general
questions
assess to open up center if they have
vulnerable pieces well
okay so let me put it this way
there's three let's imagine a situation
where there is tension in the center
okay and this is what i would call
quantify as tension right
there's two pawns that are out of
standoff there's
three fundamental things that you can do
you can not do anything and simply
continue developing
you can actively try to open up the
center more and release the tension
that's d takes e4 or
you can try to close the tension with d4
let's
uh thank you king moog for the prime
and we can transfer that to a bunch of
scenarios
um generally speaking the first of these
options
uh is what i prefer unless it is
specifically good in some way to
continue opening up the center because
generally when there is a source of
tension such as pawns at a standoff
you want your opponent to be the one to
release that tension
and help you put your pieces on better
squares my friend dana mckenzie
a national master and he's actually a
best-selling author now he calls this
moving your opponent's pieces
uh you want to be very careful about
moving your opponent's pieces your white
is essentially moving my knight
to a better square to an outpost on t5
so that is why players who are able to
keep the tension
in certain positions are very very
successful
because that is not an easy thing to do
okay
there is no algorithm that i could offer
but this is the closest i can come
for this board would you check the king
of bishop before ask trout man
good question now bishop b4 would be
good were it not for the annoying move
c3
blunting the diagonal and attacking the
bishop so
you could do this right you could drop
the bishop to a5 and then to b6 that
would be a perfectly viable maneuver
but uh if it were not for the move c3
bishop b4 would cause
some trouble although i guess white
could play bishop d2 also and develop
the bishop
i generally think that bishop before
check or bishop gefora is overrated
you want to be sort of developing with
check is good
but it's not always as good as it may
appear
[Music]